and today marking two years since tow
truck driver Ryan Billet was killed in a
hit-and-run crash while he was working
along the 215. thanks for joining us at
11 o'clock I'm Denise Valdez and I'm
Brian Loftis those who knew him are
sharing his story while encouraging
others to move over on the freeway Sasha
Loftus joins us live at Nevada State
Police Headquarters with more on their
message
Denise and Brian Those Who Loved Ryan
gathered here tonight to remember him
while others in the community also
gathered to share an ever important
message to keep everyone else safe
he lived for saving people it's been two
years since Ryan Billet lost his life he
cared about everyone he left his church
he loved country music the 48 year old
tow truck driver was working along the
215 near South Dakota when he was hit by
another driver who then drove away and
for him to see all this he would be
absolutely shocked the impact he made
his widow Rebecca one of many
remembering Ryan Thursday night as tow
truck drivers friends family and law
enforcement gathered at Nevada State
Police Headquarters to honor the man he
was Ryan is an example unfortunately of
the result of somebody not moving over
Nevada State Police Trooper Ashley
Wellman says it's also an opportunity to
share the importance of Nevada's Move
Over Law it requires drivers to move to
the far left lane when possible or slow
down whenever anyone is pulled over on
the side of the highway we want you to
see us we want you to slow down you know
we want to home to our families at the
end of the day Rebecca says she'll never
stop encouraging others to stay safe if
you see those flashing lights you need
to pull over if you can't at least slow
down just one of many ways to continue
her late husband's Legacy
now Nevada's Move Over law was first put
into place in 2003 it was then changed
in 2017 to include any kind of broken
down car or debris on the side of the
highway and of course if you were caught
not following it you can get a ticket
reporting live tonight Sasha Loftus 8
News Now